[Music]
david thanks so much it's been about a
day and a half since governor sysolak
lifted the mass mandate for public
indoor establishments did that yesterday
at 10 a.m this has brought questions
about other requirements we're talking
about testing and vaccinations to attend
venues christian costa is joining us
live across the studio tonight christian
what did you find out well brian lots of
questions as you can imagine from
yesterday's mask mandate roll back on
what is allowed and what is not to
attend events like shows concerts or
even just dining out so we checked in
with venues both off and on the strip
and this is what we found mgm resorts
telling us today that there is no
vaccination requirements for visiting
their properties or amenities certain
concerts do require proof of
vaccinations and or a negative cova test
if the artist or the production company
deems it now it's optional for
conventions meetings and gatherings i
also reached out to station casinos but
they had no comment about this matter in
downtown the smith center as well as the
golden nugget not requiring proof of
vaccination and a covet test now cirque
du soleil says guests and hotel partners
will not be required to wear masks or
show proof of vaccination for their
shows and finally masks and proof of
vaccinations are not required for fans
to attend the mountain west basketball
championships happening on march 6 over
at unlv and as a reminder it's always
best to check in with the venue that you
are attending for any changes christian
casa is live local now